to get your thoughts on this man a lot
to process from Phil's comments man
where are you with all this
um
again I I like the fact that this is
Phil I think this is Phil as honest and
sort of open as he's ever been
um the fact that Paris says that they
they were sort of no sort of oversight
by PR and you know and I and I'm sure
that was partly on Phil too he said hey
we're going to do this we're going to do
it and you know I'm gonna be a little
bit unhinged and
I think that goes a long way towards
showing like hey even though again
directly I don't know how much he had to
do with what's been happening lately it
all falls on his head and as it should
as it should and he did what a good boss
supposed to do would come out there and
and take that L and take the you know
and take all the Flack for it